Mike Ramirez is a two-time Pulitzer
winning political cartoonist who has
both drawn and written for more than 400
publications nationwide including the
New York Times The Washington Post and
National Review he currently co-manages
the editorial pages at investors
business daily where his work is
featured Ramirez is also offered
authored two books his first everyone
has the right to your to my opinion was
published in 2008 and his second give me
liberty or give me Obamacare was
published just last October please help
me in welcoming mr. Greer you know there
was this young man and he was on trial
and the judge was chastising he was
saying how could you possibly justify
such a heinous crime it's a terrible
terrible deed killing a California
condor there are only 28 of 27 of them
left in the wild what could possibly
even going through your mind to allow
you to do such a terrible thing young
man looked at the judge and you said
Your Honor I was camping I was out in
the wilderness I got lost and as I
wandered through some trees and some
brush I fell off this cliff and I landed
on this ledge I was stuck on this ledge
for seven days and seven nights with no
food no water I guess I looked pretty
bad because his giant Buzzard landed on
top of me started pecking at me with the
last ounce of strength in my body I
picked up a rock I bashed him in the
skull and I ate him as a matter of
survival as a matter of sustenance the
judge said you know that's a pretty good
reason i may just let you off just out
of curiosity what did it taste like he
said it was kind of a cross between a
bald eagle and a spotted owl
the story with the twist an element of
humor to capture your attention and then
the fatal blow in essence that's
editorial cartooning when people ask me
what does an editorial cartoonist always
say we're kind of a hybrid we're cross
between between edward r murrow marc
Stein and the Son of Sam edit all
cartoons are about concept the
illustration is merely a vehicle to
convey a point of view we're here to
protect and inform the public to attack
and repeal those who do not share our
long-term philosophical interests and
you know basically you can see I get
paid to be obnoxious it's the only other
profession besides being a professor
we're being a dentist's where you get
paid to be obnoxious politicians will
have you think they're paid to be
obnoxious they're not paid to be there
just obnoxious that's why we have
editorial cartoonists it's a profession
about ideas ninety-five percent of what
I do is concept or pushing a particular
point of view we are the pit bulls of
journalism and we're trained attack at
the slightest provocation we're the
prosecution pushing for a rapid
conviction and an immediate execution we
are the defense punching holes in the
arguments raised against our cause we
are judged we are jury and since I'm not
a member of the Ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals my judgments actually makes
sense and we stand in judgment over the
issues and the sense that we love you
swift and harsh but in order to be judge
and jury clearly you have to be informed
you have to read and research so I'm a
pretty boring job I basically get paid
to read and analyze start around five
o'clock in the in the morning every day
every day and I watch the news at every
half hour just to try to get a sense of
what's being absorbed by the American
consciousness I read for papers a day I
read The Wall Street Journal the New
York Times the Los Angeles Times and the
Orange County Register a lot of people
in a question whether the truth lies
somewhere between the New York Times
editorial page in the wall street
journal editorial page it lies at
Michael P Vermeer's calm
i'm also a capitalist pig so you know
I'm a political analyst I'm a political
want walk I get paid to read and I read
everything I can get my hands on is a
contributor to the weekly standard of
course they read the Weekly Standard i
read the National Review I you know if I
want to get laughs I'll read Mother
Jones or watch MSNBC I think it's
important to view issues on the on the
broadest possible reference plane in
fact i think if you firmly believe in
any issue i urge you to read the
opposite there's an evolution of thought
now most times i think it will merely
reinforce your original beliefs but
every once in a while on the rare
occasion it might change your mind and
in order to construct an argument you
really have to know the opposite side of
that argument either way i think you'll
have a larger and more comprehensive
view of the issue and i think that's
important i believe it's important to
understand all sides of an issue and
that entails knowing the contrary view
i'm a believer in the statement know
thine enemy so I'm constantly on the
obama website now editorial cartoonists
we spend our time gathering information
we we process the information to draw a
conclusion to draw a cartoon and
hopefully to draw blood now
unfortunately the modern trend in
editorial cartoon eden has been to make
simple jokes about current affairs i
think humor without a substantive
message without a substance statement
diminishes the importance of an
editorial cartoon i'm a big believer of
edit or cartooning as journalism an
editor tool cartina is not just a funny
picture a good edit or cartoon is a fine
instrument of journalism at times I
think it's sharp and refined its message
cutting quickly to the point at times
blunt with its dark imagery seizing the
reader's attention and as with any
editorial the cartoon has a point that's
the most important element that's what i
want to emphasize today it defines an
issue it tells a story the challenge is
hypocrisy it reveals the best and the
worst of humanity it calls the reader to
arms in the battle against the
complacent the lethargic the evildoers
the indolent body politic
and the champions of the status quo it
exposes the assorted predators of
society and by that I mean politicians
but a good editorial cartoon should not
only be well researched it should be
carefully contemplated so one of the
most important aspects of my job is not
just deciding which cartoons to do but
which cartoons not to do I think I've
talked to some of you about it earlier
today the first thing that came to mind
was a cartoon on Johnnie Cochran if
you're unfamiliar with Johnny he was the
guy who defended OJ Simpson and got him
off on the murder case and when Johnny
died you know the big the big thing in
the trial was that Johnny showed that
the glove did not fit on oj simpson and
he said if the glove don't fit you have
to acquit so when Johnny died the first
image that came to my mind was Johnny at
the at the gates of heaven and Saint
Peter was saying I'm sorry Johnny but if
the halo don't fit we don't admit now
now that's a pretty straightforward
cartoon but upon investigating Johnny
Cochran I found a guy who was engaged in
many charitable causes and very very
generous and it seemed unfair to define
him on one issue so I took a pass on the
cartoon another example is this space
shuttle Challenger where seven American
heroes died a lot of people lay the
blame to that catastrophe on the fact
that NASA's efforts to curb spending and
cutting corners had created this safety
problem and so the idea that came to
mind was showing little pieces of the
shuttle flying across the sky with a
bubble coming out of one of the little
pieces saying man these these NASA
cutbacks are killing us it's a
legitimate point but seven American
heroes died and it wasn't worth to have
this cartoon overshadowed by the
controversy surrounding that element of
the cartoon and obscuring the point that
I was trying to make an edit or cartoon
isn't humorous for the sake of humor
it's not controversial for the sake of
controversy it's neither conservative
nor liberal whether you agree with it
philosophically or not a good editorial
cartoon engages the reader and
debate it informs and it a challenge 'as
it draws the reader into the democratic
process and i think edit or cartoon
should do more than a fan but i also
believe that the right to offend must be
defended and we talked a little bit
about Charlie head bow on the Paris
attack there's a quote often attributed
to Volterra but it's actually Evelyn
Beatrice Hall who says I disapprove of
what you say but I will defend to the
death your right to say it this freedom
of information must always be protected
John Milton in 1644 said give me liberty
to know to uh turn to argue freely
according to conscience above all
liberties the Declaration of the Rights
of Man in the citizen which was approved
by the National Assembly of France in
1789 written by Marquis de Lafayette
declared that freedom of speech was a
natural an irritable sacred right of man
the idea of a universal freedom of
speech has been around for four
centuries and you know we've we've seen
the hustler case versus Falwell even
obnoxious speech has to be protected the
reason being that in a governing
Democratic Republic this free flow of
information is so very important to
protect our liberties we've seen with
this administration both surfers
assertions that the war on terror is
over al-qaeda is on the run even
assuring us in the last State of the
Union that the shadow of crisis has
passed and we turned our page on on
terror and President Obama said over and
over repeatedly that the world is a
safer place none of which is true and
this is an administration that can't
even use the words radical Islam and
it's a naive belief that disengagement
from the world is going to make America
safer our policy of leading from behind
has left a vacuum of power that's been
quickly filled with chaos and mal
faction now imagine a world that did not
have the freedom or the journalists were
the editorial cartoonists and a free and
impress to point at point that out as
the light of liberty is dimmed so are
the prospects for a peaceful and safer
world I think this tragedy in Paris
demonstrates a need to shine the light
of exposure on those who subvert
religion to justify brutal acts of
barbarity and only when the world can
see clearly these these people for what
they truly are will the world unite
against these emissaries of death so
whether you agree with the cartoons or
not as a material freedom must endure
you know in the Declaration of
Independence Thomas Jefferson wrote we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal but that
we are endowed by our creator with
certain unalienable happiness but while
these rights are indeed endowed by a
creator and guaranteed by our
Constitution it is government that
upholds these liberties and it as men
who constitute the government there are
those who believe that the Constitution
is merely a starting point for
negotiation James Madison wrote i
believe there are more instances of the
abridgement of the freedom of people by
gradual and silent encroachments by
those empower them by violent and sudden
usurpations I think we're clearly seeing
evidence of that today journalism
editorial cartoons are checked to the
erosion of our liberties and part of the
first line of defense to the advance of
the unrestrained power of government one
good edit or cartoon can have a
significant impact on the political
dialogue of the day if done well I think
it can influence those who govern to
govern responsibly and expose them when
they do not you know Einstein once said
two things are infinite the universe and
human stupidity and I'm not sure about
the universe
Einstein was right it's this axiom which
makes political cartooning so important
these people who ultimately govern will
make mistakes they're human after all
most of them anyways but history is
demonstrated that power can turn leaders
into monsters and edit old cartoonists
will gladly point out the shortcomings
of the powerful and an effort to keep
them human there's a reason our founding
fathers included the right to a free
press and the First Amendment of our
Constitution information is a necessary
component to guide you in a political
system based on self-governance and
individual liberty information is power
I think we talked a little bit about it
in some of the classes today imagine if
he knew about this little computer
company called the Apple computer back
in nineteen eighty and when it when you
can purchase a hundred shares of its IPO
at twenty-two dollars a share it be
worth close to half a million dollars
today Thomas Jefferson once wrote our
Liberty depends on the freedom of the
press then that cannot be limited
without it being lost you know I think a
free press is a check to government
power it's the daylight and the dark
arena of politics that provides the
voter with information to decide their
own future but frankly the press has to
do its job and unfortunately it seems
like the most that the only people more
incompetent than this administration
seems to be the Washington press corps
in our reporter job is to be the
purveyor of fact to point out the end
justices of the world to shine the hot
spotlight of exposure to win the
perpetrators of those and justices with
the truth editorial cartoonist we just
go back and shoot the wounded now I need
to make a distinction here between the
objective news reporting segments of
journalism and the subjective editorial
page I always find it funny when people
call me up and they say well they don't
call me mr. Ramirez they call me other
names
they say you are way too opinionated and
I have to explain to them that's why I'm
on the opinion page and I understand why
because it's hard to distinguish between
the two that's the failure of today's
journalism the truth is the mainstream
media does an awful job I think that's
why people trust the media less than
they put trust the politicians if you
can imagine that it's a factor and I
think circulations going down I mean
obviously there's the advent of new
technology and there's a convergence of
media where people were relying on the
web for information but why would you
want to pay for misinformation when you
can just get it for free on the web
there's widespread speculation and
manipulation going on in the media it's
kind of traversed from gathering
information to infotainment and I'm
opposed to that you know I was I gave a
speech down at the Reagan Library and
during the anniversary of Ronald Reagan
last year they were talking a lot about
how what a great communicator Ronald
Reagan was but there was much more to
Ronald Reagan to that but from the media
that's all you would really here I think
he was perhaps the greatest president of
modern times and he provides us a good
lesson in presidential leadership now
true was his oratorical skills that made
Reagan such a potent force but it was it
was his ideas and unwavering belief in
America's greatness that made him great
now if you've been to the reagan museum
they have a little clip where Reagan's
hosting a bunch of edito cartoonists at
the White House I just happen to be one
of them I'm in the second row I actually
had hair back then but one thing I loved
about Ronald Reagan was his sense of
humor the joke he told that day was
about the difference between the United
States and the Soviet Union democracy
versus communism and he said the
difference between the United States and
the Soviet Union is that in the United
States political cartoonist can draw
cartoons of the President
of the United States and the Soviet
Union political cartoonists must draw
cartoons on the President of the United
States you know Ronald Reagan was
essentially an editorial cartoonist but
with words his jokes were funny but they
always had a cogent point take the you
know the resurrection of the Cold War
now with Putin and the cold war with
usss are on March eighth nineteen
eighty-three ronald reagan declared the
soviet union the evil empire the
reaction was immediate a blanket of
condemnation arose from the political
pundits and the mainstream media critics
and conventional wisdom called reagan's
remarks unpresidential an abrogation of
diplomacy they characterize them as a
doddering old man barely in charge of
his mental faculties who was unaware of
what he was saying of course he said
much much worse but in the most remote
part of Siberia deep in a gulag and a
dark damp in dingy cell a sympathetic
guard leaned over to a political
prisoner Soviet dissident and he quietly
whispered between the iron bars of a
cell President Reagan has just called
the Soviet Union the evil empire that
statement hung there in the air for a
moment the guard left him in the
darkness of his cell and quietly the
metallic sound of a worn spoon tapped
against stone repeating the news in wars
code which echoed along the walls of the
gulag Ronald Reagan is called the Soviet
Union the evil empire one spoon tapping
out the hopes of those imprisoned in the
darkness one spoon followed by another
and followed by another until it bursts
into a cacophony of defiance see words
have meaning and reagan's words marked
the beginning of the end of the soviet
empire reagan was a crusader against
evil and he boldly challenge mr.
Gorbachev tear down the wall and it did
words have power
but words are only powerful if their
foot there pursued with meaning and
purpose commitment in action and the
collapse of the Soviet Union was only
one facet of Reagan's achievements he
provides a good model of the path back
for America and remember America was
suffering under Jimmy Carter and what
Reagan did was he took us from the
darkness he was stored funding and
established a strong national defense
and advocated a diplomatic policy of
peace through strength he pledged a
reduced government programs he pushed a
25-percent across-the-board tax cut in
income taxes the largest in history he
stopped apologizing for us wealth and us
might and he projected America's
greatness he was a free-market
capitalist but what what Reagan believed
in more than anything was the power of
the people not the institution of
government that the exceptional nature
of America lied within its exceptional
people it was a uniquely American idea
rather than apologize for America he
made America believe in itself again he
believed in the power of the people
rather than the government to find the
answers to our problems Reagan believed
that the government would just get out
of the way Americans could provide the
solutions in comparison you look at the
Obama administration this is what my
book is on I was trying to think of what
the title was going to be when I first
got together with Simon & Schuster they
rejected conservatives are from Mars
progressives are from uranus they
rejected the illustrated guide for
impeachment
but I start off the book by saying the
Peter Principle is when a person is
elevated to their level of a competence
the Obama principles when that person
gets elected president of the United
States you know it's kind of funny
everybody's lauding Donald Trump for his
bluntness and obnoxiousness I've been
doing that for my entire career you know
I'm an equal-opportunity offender but
with this administration editorial
cartooning is more like stenography than
anything creative when people ask me how
do you come up with your ideas always
say you know I've got the best gag
writer in the world working for me in
the Oval Office every single day when
he's not on vacation or on a golf course
his policies are the joke his speeches
are the setup and their failure are the
punch line except nobody's laughing
because it hurts far too much to laugh
Einstein once said intellectuals solve
problems geniuses prevent them Obama
creates them remember when Obama's chief
of staff Rahm Emanuel said you never
want a serious crisis to go to waste
well taking those words so hard his
administration to spend two terms
creating crisis after crisis you know I
wanted to examine his his record but
there's just so much here we just don't
have enough time to pour through it all
these statistics I wrote of when I wrote
the introduction of the book which was
about a year ago but to just to show you
the disaster that we've inherited his
policy of appeasement and leading from
behind his diminished our global
reputation alienated our allies and
boldin our enemies Islam extremism and
the prospect of terrorism our post-911
world continues to expand when you think
about it 911 you know basically he had
19 guys funded by saudi millionaires and
now with Isis you have about fifteen to
thirty thousand fighters that are
circulating through Isis training camps
learning to kill people and being
imported back into their countries of
residence radical Islamic groups control
more territory now than ever
and Iran controls Lebanon Syria gaiman
in Iraq worse Iran has grown ever closer
to developing nuclear weapons and
starting that's not even the worst part
starting a nuclear arms race in a region
that's a wash and oil money but lacks
reverence for human life look mutually
assured destruction is not a deterrent
to those who are willing to die for
their cause and there are 13 additional
nations in the African continent in the
Middle East that are now pursuing
nuclear technology when you expand that
number of 9 nuclear nations to you know
a low 20s to people that don't believe
that human life is that important it
becomes a very dangerous world China has
began to flex its muscles and threaten
its neighbors Russia has invaded hers
under President Obama the world's become
a much more dangerous place especially
for Americans and when you think of
domestic policy in our economy the u.s.
household medium income levels dropped
twelve percent in the six years between
2007 and 2013 I choose out 2013 incomes
had dropped twice as much during the
recovery than it did during the
recession more than 48 a million million
Americans were living in poverty
including one in five adults 65 percent
of children are living in households
which received one or more forms of
federal aid forty six point four million
Americans are on food stamps the labor
participation rate is the lowest since
1978 the you sexy u6 unemployment rate
is 11.5 percent during the Obama
administration we witnessed the
first-ever credit downgrade in US
history during the Obama administration
we witnessed the second-ever credit
downgrade and US history and for what
purpose they wanted to Olivier this this
financial gap between the wealthy and
the poor but we've seen a dramatic
increase in income income inequality
black and minority families have been
hit the
artists the wealth of white households
was thirteen times a median wealth of
blacks in 2013 which is seven times
greater than in 2010 the root cause of
all of this has been the substantial
growth in government regulations
subsidies programs just big government
and now they want to give everybody free
college I know that's a good idea for
you guys but we have 120 trillion
dollars in unfunded liabilities from our
current entitlement programs and 20
trillion dollars in debt de Tocqueville
once said the American Republic will
endure until the day Congress discovers
that it can bribe the people with its
own money I wonder what de Tocqueville
would say if you ever met President
Barack Obama I was going to list the
going to go through the list of economic
failures but it's just too long to go
through i was going to also named all
the things he blamed but that's even
longer than the list of failures and i
was going to mention the scandals but
that's twice as long as that you know
it's amazing what this president's been
able to get away with I think it's been
the most unlawful anti-constitutional
administration we've had in a long time
we were just talking about over dinner
about how this administration has taken
Americans out of a out of the
presidential election cycle for two and
a half years with no consequences
whatsoever that's not supposed to happen
in the United States that happens in
Venezuela you know the president's abuse
of executive authority has taken with
new heights of lawless behavior you know
for a constitutional professor I wonder
if you ever heard of montesquieu were
the separation of powers even liberal
constitutional scholar constitutional
scholar and George Washington University
Law Professor Jonathan Turley called
President Obama the president richard
nixon always wanted to be
I think it's a natural national disgrace
I think it's time to get to the truth I
think newspapers and the media have an
obligation to give you the truth not a
filtered version of the truth not a
politically correct version of the truth
that's simply the truth now we're all
human beings and most of the journalists
are therefore well there they will
undoubtedly have their own
interpretation of events but I think
that's what makes it so important to
cover an issue in its entirety the
differing perceptions can easily color
an issue let me give you an example
sherlock holmes and watson went on a
camping trip and as they lay down to
sleep homes turn to Watson who said
Watson look up into the sky and tell me
what you see and once and thought about
it for a minute and he said well I see
millions and millions of stars in home
said well what does that tell you and
Watson replied well astronomically it
tells me that there are millions of
galaxies and potentially billions of
planets theologically to create
something as magnificent as this there
must be a god and god is great and we
are small and insignificant
meteorological e tells me well it's a
beautiful clear evening sky is probably
going to be a beautiful day tomorrow
then Watson turn to homes and he said
what does it tell you and Holmes looked
up and he said somebody stole our tent
we have a participatory Democratic
Republic the best system of governance
in the world truly a government by the
people for the people of the people but
only if the people participate I have to
tell this joke because I just like it
there was this duck and he went into the
store he waddled up to the manager and
he said got any grapes and the manager
looked at this duck and he said no dr.
dome walked out ten months later the
stuck comes Wadley nian goes up the
manager says got any grapes manager
looks at the duck and he goes I said no
we have no grapes duck goes all walks
out
10 minutes later the duck comes waddling
in goes up to the mattress has got any
grapes the manager goes when is wrong
with you I have no grapes I will never
have grapes I've no fruit Department no
grapes kozel walks out 10 minutes later
the debt comes waddling in goes up the
manager says got any grapes now says
what is wrong with you I don't like
grapes I don't like ducks get out of my
store duck goes all walks out 10 minutes
later the duck comes waddling in the
manager goes hold it right there duck if
you ask me for grapes one more time I'm
going to nail your little web feet to
the floor ask me for anything else but
don't ask me for grapes the doc looked
at him and said got any nails he says no
got any grapes you see this joke
provides a good working analogy of how I
view Washington bureaucracies of work
because you see in Washington DC things
are not always represented as they truly
are for example a slower increase in
Medicare payments is not called a
rational effort to save Medicare it's
called the draconian cut a balanced
budget amendment which stipulates
Congress can only spend the amount of
money that they knew they take in is not
called common sense is called extremism
making illegal immigration illegal is
not called following the law it's called
insensitivity judging someone not by the
content of their character but strictly
by the color of their skin is not called
racism it's called the firm rid of
action aborting a human fetus in its
third trimester is not called killing
it's called the choice when governments
have a surplus it doesn't mean we paid
bless you it doesn't mean we've paid too
much in taxes it means we've spent too
little and services and a tax is no
longer a tax it's called an investment
in American help Vice President Biden
said it's a three-letter word patriotism
there is no global war on terror it's
called an overseas contingency operation
the Fort Hood attack was was called
workplace violence they called the
Muslim Brotherhood a largely secular
group which is a shirred violence the
Muslim Brotherhood secular it has a word
Muslim in its name the Islamic state is
neither Islamic or state they won't use
the word radical Islam or Islamic
extremists and blowing up buildings is
no longer called terrorism it's called a
man cause disaster frankly I think this
administration has been a man cause
disaster and I don't know about you but
I believe in the old adage if it walks
like a duck and it talks like a duck
then it's usually a duck as an editorial
cartoonist it's my job to nail that duck
to the floor because someone needs to
watch over the institution for the
intellectually challenged excuse me the
Obama administration on behalf of the
American public politicians often forget
who they work for because of the pomp
and circumstance that surrounds these
career political celebrities were lulled
into thinking it is we who work for them
when it is the opposite it is they who
work for you they are public servants
they're elected to do your bidding and
believe me they are far from and have
infallible the problem with this country
isn't that we pay too little in taxes
and said we support a government that's
gotten too big and too intrusive our
country was built around the idea of
self-governance and independence the
thirty-nine percent of Americans are on
some kind of government program one in
six Americans are on direct government
assistance forty-seven percent of
Americans do not pay federal taxes in
the last election we had less than fifty
eight percent turnout of all registered
voters if you took the real numbers of
the eligible electorate less than a
third twenty-nine percent voted for the
president of the most powerful nation in
the world is this America you want you
guys are the future it certainly isn't
the America the Ronald Reagan envisioned
it's amazing when you look back into
history at
small group of colonies united to fight
taxation without representation it's
clearly evident now that we face the
same challenge you know I would much
rather be constitutionally correct and
politically correct I think anyone who
cannot delineate between radical Islam
and Islam illegal immigration and
emigration an assault rifle and a long
rifle an automatic weapon and a weapon
that just looks like an automatic weapon
can't distinguish between pleat the
police and criminals and the lies and
the truth they do not deserve the job as
president of the United States of
America there's a quote attributed to
George Washington that says government
is not reason it is not eloquence it is
a force like fire it is a dangerous
servant and a fearful master I don't
think it's actually his quo but Calvin
Coolidge John F Kennedy and Ronald
Reagan found the solution to our
economic problems rested not in the
government but in the ingenuity of the
people they believed in the doctrine of
American exceptionalism in their eyes
America was a place where the
extraordinary could be extraordinary in
and be rewarded for their success in
turn their success would create
innovations and jobs that benefit the
average American and give the average
Americans incentives to work hard to
dream hard to become extraordinary
themselves so that others could simply
remain as community organizers President
Clinton believed in an America that
could reach for the moon not reach for
the taxpayers wallets president obama
can give a good speech but it takes more
than words in a good speech to make a
great president it takes great ideas
Reagan was it was an exceptional
president because he truly believed
America was an exceptional country
Ronald Reagan saw America as a shining
city on a hill not just a city among
many many other cities as we embark on
this presidential election cycle
don't be disheartened I believe in
America I because I believe in its
people we will find our way you are the
future of America it is your
responsibility as citizens of this Grand
Republic to be informed to find the
truth find the deep root of what our
founding fathers believed in that made
America so great so I'm going to leave
you with that challenge and I'm going to
try to inspire you with some cartoons so
many dim the lights can we dim the
lights thanks now being the capitalist
pig that I am this is my book so please
buy it my friend Dick Cheney wrote the
intro and it's actually pretty fun to
forward it is pretty funny and rushed to
the via backwards this is my website in
defense of Liberty Michael P Ramirez
dicom you can find me on Facebook and
Twitter and all that stuff now this is
why I do my job this is a picture of
Bill Clinton he's looking over the
demilitarized zone between north and
south korea if you look closely the
binoculars they have a lens caps on
George W doing the same thing America's
behind you one hundred percent except on
these blackout dates which include
vacations and golf outings and TV shows
Hillary's health problem
he attorney it's a reflex building a
wall confetti it's Hilary shredded
emails I was amazing i know this is
hilary which is Obama's third term don't
worry gets worse just uh my view of the
Olympics now I thought of this be i
thought i'd throw this in because i'm
traveling as part of the tsa efficiency
program those 65 and older do not have
to remove their shoes I was 50 when I
got in line this is a car team that
actually did today despite America being
a country of imperious bullies racist
polluters and greedy capitalists who
torture and want to build walls I
believe we've been a force for good we
determine with starting those massive
fires Hillary Clinton's pants now liar
liar pants on fire now I thought I'd
throw this in here this is the evolution
of a car chain a lot of you to ask me
how I do this and they start off as
little gems on cocktail napkins and they
look like this so all um I think about
issues all the time and I just jot these
down the funny thing about it is it's
the image that I see in my mind and what
you're going to see is a transformation
from this into a final cartoon but it
pretty much looks the same except i'm
filling in the details so that's the
cocktail napkin this is what the sketch
looks at what looks like and what I do
with these sketches on copy papers I
scan them into my computer and I send
them to I've eight friends that I send
the cartoons out to you to get their
feedback and then I just completely
ignore what they say and pick out the
ones i like this is what the the initial
black and white drawing looks like
and you know the great thing about a
computer is you can manipulate things I
will add a screen on the computer to put
this kind of diagonal line stuff on
there and give it more depth and because
the newspapers that take my cartoons
take both black and white and color I
have to make a separate black and white
version of the cartoon so that's it to
this I add the color base and I just
kind of splash it on and Photoshop has a
wonderful tool where if you hit the open
areas it will cut all the color out it
shouldn't be there it produces this and
so this is the this is the basic
template of a cartoon with its initial
color from there I'll add color and
texture to it and that's the finished
drawing right there this is my Pulitzer
entry from last year we don't have a
complete strategy on Isis Isis does this
is a bomb erasing our borders and the
kourt's putting them back so now
political cartoons they're not always
funny they but they should always make
you think this is what Obama meant when
he said al-qaeda is on the run Hillary
your email problems are beginning to
worry us you've got jail
and if you'll notice my cartoons I'll
just throw a little stuff in there this
is the modern-day slavery state Jerry
Brown the Governor of California
reservoirs what California obviously
needs or shorter showers and a high
speed rail this reservoir is nearly
empty if we were aware of the evil back
then with the world have prevented and
and that's one thing I should tell you
about I just visited Baghdad in October
I've been off throughout Iraq visiting
the troops in Iraq is really all these
cities are separated by long highways
when you go into Baghdad you leave from
ali saleem air base which is a
northernmost air base that we have in
kuwait and you get there along the
60-mile highway of death if you remember
the first desert storm we had asked the
Iraqis to surrender instead they
proceeded to go northward through Kuwait
and rape and pillage their way through
the country so we caught him out in the
open highway and obliterated them now
the first time I look up Isis and
googled it the first image that I got
was an eight-year-old little girl in a
sunday dress who'd been beheaded now
obviously the president was more privy
too far worse stuff than that and he
must have known Isis is basically the
reconstituted forces of al-qaeda and
Iraq Saddam's old military core and he
must have known they're coming from the
northern border and they could have
caught them out in the open and just
obliterated them before they reached the
oil fields before they started taking
towns this is a tragedy the evolution of
man to Caitlyn Jenner
so bhama taken to the cleaners on the
nuclear deal I think I get a good
nuclear deal in hand the Planned
Parenthood fetal harvest chart refugee
roulette and you know we're talking
about this during dinner to that we need
to make a distinction between immigrants
and refugees I think refugees because
you can't really vet them it's really
now what's which relative do you want to
die to sacrifice to ensure this you can
set up a safety zone in the territories
near the countries where they can be
safe until they return back to their
country this is the lack of fiscal
responsibility by Greece and a portrait
of America's future the State Department
claimed that the lack of jobs were
behind the rise of Isis here's a guy
saying I can get a job beheading people
on the private side and this is a you
know the Sanchez who shot that gallant
San Francisco on the people that are
culpable in the more and the murder
which is the Obama immigration policy in
the sanctuary city policy this is the
Clinton Foundation bags and bags of
foreign money mutual assured destruction
only works when the other side doesn't
want to die weekend at Bernie's she's
just passed out them how dare you call
us a do-nothing Congress why i oughtta
mr. president you may not believe in
that early Islam but radical Islam
believes in you and this is for the
Paris attack the pen is mightier than
the sword this is my book there's more
this is a young Barack Obama all those
cartoons were my entry from last year
these are in the book this is a Barack
Obama if you notice all the questions
the answer is government except for one
democracy is a form of social inequality
he certainly has a lot of Secret Service
for protection those are journalists the
Imperial President Congress is in
session when I say it is good news
captain we have a ship a full ship 7.1
million passengers on the Obama kvamme
care Titanic and this is your new doctor
Karl Marx
give me liberty or give me a government
bailout de Blasio's new york city when
cheryl atkinson left CBS News she took
the sea and she left the BS I was dead
broke that'll be two hundred thousand
dollars please what do you call doing
the same thing over and over again and
expecting different results California
this is the Gosnell clinic tragedy with
the aborted babies never again relax i'm
only going to hit him on the upper two
percent of his body and we were talking
about this earlier remember you're
asking me how long it takes to do a
cartoon this was really quick because
there's just nothing but garbage back
there none of that medical equipment
really exists it's just stuff that's
lying around my office why I have that
kind of stuff flying around my offices
another question the mountain of debt
someday all this will be yours it's very
difficult it's very complicated cut
spending made in China the unemployment
line the Obamacare death panel let's
start with jobs here's the obamas green
economy which is run out of gas this is
how electric cars work you have to plug
them into coal plants to make them work
global cooling global warming climate
change climate disruption it's called
weather
I like the equals MC Hammer there's all
kinds of stuff and there's something
about Al Gore he often find it
extinguishing the light of Liberty
through the EPA now Nancy Pelosi was
gonna they're going to rename a street
after her these are my suggestions here
she is again I've drained the swamp of
Washington corruption I'm sorry miss
Warren the Bolsheviks are not an Indian
tribe never mind it's not a red line
it's just blood the reset button
negotiate for a couple more weeks we
suspect China may be stealing
information the Obama administration
Iran nuclear policy autocrats despot
sand terrorists start your programs
attention everyone as you going to
battle the most important thing for you
to know his Jones here is gay
this is when we cop in laden beating
swords into food stamps this is a
abandoning Iraq don't forget your golf
clubs mr. president so you want to use
you want yep now that's exactly what it
is in fact you utilize I was going to
say you utilize iconic images that
people can relate to to make the point
and when people look at that they think
of the abandonment of Vietnam here we
have the abandonment of Iraq we
recommend boots on the ground we
recommend boots on the ground we
recommend boots on the ground we
recommend boots in the ground Obama has
the boots / 0 so he doesn't have to
listen to them remember I was talking
about the little stuff that I put in the
Oval Office like the I love you and all
the pictures in the background or of his
loved ones yeah the knight in shiny
armor you didn't build that somebody
else made that happen King George the
third built the roads this is this is my
illustration of chris matthews you
wonder why has a tingle up his leg
limited government you bunch of
extremists we the government the tip of
the iceberg I still can't get on the
website the selfie Obama is Nero to the
Foley family I want you to know all my
thoughts are with you of course you
wouldn't have to play golf that same day
Jimmy Carter thank you
the fading light of liberty now this is
my first book everyone has the right to
my opinion i'm going to show you some
cartoons you can kind of see the
evolution of the style over the years
the 94 pulitzer collection it depends on
what the meaning of is is William
Jefferson Clinton this is on US Japan
trade aren't these supposed to face you
when they bow and in line of the
modernization society we'd like to
renegotiate the Ten Commandments down to
four and a half moral values if it were
not for reporters I would tell you the
truth chester a arthur this is our moral
fabric i think this is my favorite
cartoon because it's concise and
immediate father you can't say prayers
during graduation ceremonies but if you
print them on condoms we'd be happy to
distribute them what I want to do on
Father's Day meet my father so at the
forty seven percent of legitimacy rate
in Memphis Tennessee here's a black man
with a black kid a white man with a
white kid the black man's thinking white
the white man's thinking black the kids
are going look another kid unsupervised
children sliding into gangs you two here
to be married yes will step up and be
counted by society we try to impose its
moral values on us is beyond me for it's
perfectly natural to people and love to
want to get married your father should
be proud of you he is my father when
Eliot Spitzer had his news conference I
thought they should put the microphones
where his brain was
Hollywood you can fool all the people
some of the time and some of the people
all the time but you cannot fool all the
people all the time Abraham Lincoln in
ancient times people worship the stars
out of ignorance who would counsel Eve
glamorized drugs and tobacco just for
profit Hollywood son your father and I
decided not to let you watch television
anymore because it promotes violence
touch my remote and I'll kill you
remember when Michael Jackson was
holding the baby over the banister this
is what the baby was thanking Michael
Jackson's my father oh please let go
here's a sister Janet the wardrobe
malfunction today I'm Martha Stewart
Living i'll be demonstrating how to cook
your own goose jr. is time to take your
lipitor not now mom and playing baseball
I'm not just a reader of the news pause
next paragraph mobile country because of
the soaring cost of medical malpractice
insurance we don't have any doctors left
however rest assured we have the best
lawyers operating on you today this is
when the Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals
ruled against a pledge of allegiance
bryson Bobo the clown was all booked up
so we got the next best thing are you
really from the Ninth Circuit Court of
Appeals Viva bilingual education and
here to share his personal success story
through bilingual education is Miguel k
we need better immigration laws
profiling is politically incorrect
besides they pose no real threat to us
well you have a slight temperature we're
not sure why so we're going to have to
amputate your legs
freeze homicide burglary worse trans fat
raise your hands and step away from the
chicken here's Barry Bonds trying to
fill babe ruth shoes proving that
steroids do not make you bigger this is
a US border fence with the service
entrance the business of America is
business Calvin Coolidge I'm okay I
landed on a taxpayer I wish we had free
medical care like in Cuba I wish we had
good medical care like in the United
States remember Fidel imported his
doctor from Spain government is not
reason you heard that quote by George
Washington this is some of my favorite
time the Clinton administration this is
the parking meter in the Lincoln Bedroom
the stain I did not have factual
relations with the American people like
I'm the one who needs to be neuter this
is hid the Clinton Memorial his pants
around his ankles this is the Clinton
autobiography with the pullout I think
that's miss me this is the US Senate
Republicans at the trough feeding trough
now Nancy Pelosi as Speaker of the House
wanted to her own former transportation
you wanted her own jet I thought she had
her own form of transportation already
Jimmy Carter this is anatomically
correct by the way nothing brings out
the lower traits of human nature like
office seeking rutherford b hayes this
is kerry sutra on the many positions of
Johnny John Kerry is there anything in
the wardrobe to make him look thinner
here's the answer Ronald Reagan 100
times Dennis Kucinich of course I've
seen a UFO how do you think I got here
we are a nation that has a government
not the other way around that makes us
special among the nations of the earth
Ronald Wilson Reagan yes Helion someday
all this will be yours as Roberta is
Russia reverting back to Soviet style
oppression you're darned Putin the
United Nations oh and giving my
allowance Putin what's the matter never
seen a dolphin before I got into a lot
of trouble for this cartoon this is Iran
and the spread of chaos and terrorism if
a civilizations to survive you must
cultivate the science of human
relationships ability of all peoples of
all kinds to live together in the same
world at peace Franklin Delano Roosevelt
is the first intifada how dare you
defend yourself now imagine if we had
Rockets coming over the border from
Tijuana hundreds and hundreds of rockets
what would America do the price of
freedom is eternal vigilance this is a
cartoon i did on September 11 the lack
of
coordination between the intelligence
agencies I got it I got it I've never
seen a pessimistic general win a battle
Mikey eisenhower this is before the Iraq
Iran Iraq war she's say run this is the
case against Saddam now when I was in
Baghdad I was at the bath its
headquarters all the bath is
headquarters in the major cities had
swimming pools this one had bloodstains
on the swimming pool it's never filled
with water fifty thousand reasons why
the world is better off without Saddam
Hussein bless you this is a 2008
Pulitzer collection or part of it I have
no idea what it is but I feel strangely
attracted to it excuse me but I'm going
to need that to run my car this is the
great wall between product safety
inspections in Chinese factories I
pledge no more personal attacks on my
drug addicted possibly Muslim opponent
this is the CBS anchor fashions for the
ignorant celebrity see words have
meaning icons have meanings as well for
the last time if you don't tell us where
you planted the nuclear device will have
no choice but to appoint a lawyer for
you this is the difference between the
ATM and the amt I love this cartoon
because it's based on a true story meet
show a crow she only uses one square of
toilet paper / bathroom visit to fight
global warming can she's holding our
hand out yes because entwine us shake it
can you turn up the lights please
okay yeah i love i love hillsdale you
guys are doing great things here and you
are truly the Future Leaders of America
and as you look toward your future
realize that everything you do will have
an effect on on the world around you I
think America is an exceptional country
because the exceptional roots this grand
experiment that we establish our
foundation on I thank all of you when
you get a chance to revisit those
foundations Hillsdale is an excellent
place to do that to find out what makes
America extraordinary and what makes
America extraordinary is all of you so I
leave this challenge to you because I
want somebody to pay for my social
security so I thank you for having me
here
many questions yes questions yes well
thanks library available digitally
because it as an educator where I use
your work is in teaching and night let
me get your email first off so I can
send you a bill no I'm just kidding well
thanks you know what melissa is in
charge my website and we're slowly
constructing the archives of the website
that's a good idea but you know for the
time being you can actually buy my two
books and get a pretty good significant
collection there but that that is a
great idea and some sometime when I'm
not focusing on making political
cartoons we'll see if maybe Melissa and
I can work on that and get that done
because we want it we want to increase
traffic on the website too so I'm sure
there's something we can figure out you
know unfortunately the LA Times had a
very big archive not only the cartoons
they did for the LA Times but the ones I
did a commercial appeal but when we
severed that relationship they severed
that website so but the books chock full
of them any other questions is it warm
in here it is a little
you